いい
蔵はやってる人キャプテンいう家っていうくらいに入って嫌です
こんにちははじめ社長です皆さん芸セットはよく行きますか増税前によくあるわね
分かりましたこの丸い労務額になってって何かお菓子とか一フォルダーと買ったかよく
わかんないですけどそれがおかしいとかフィギュアとかなんかチロルチョコ入ってね
こうなってるのがあってずっと勝って動いて言っていい
現地に行って落として来なかった
うわあああああ
今ので伝わったらいいんですけどもなんかその100円でこういうのが取れる
ufoキャッチャーなんか道熊みたいなやつあるじゃないですかあん中で多分皆さん見
たことあると思うんですけどもちょっと持ってきます
[拍手]
[音楽]
で満点では
そんなファイルねべ系方ありますか
はぁ
ねえやれそれでいい
これらのゲーセンで見たことある人多いと思うんですけど
なんか工場やつねなんかゲーセンでよくないですか ufoキャッチャーとかハズレと
かによくあると思うんですがこう言う
なんか
いわゆる
好きぽやですねこれ前なんか100円でポンチねすぐ多分全部あげ待ってみたいな感じ
だと思うんですけどそれを今回ちょっとあのできるだけ買ってみました
解析中はいというわけで多分4万円分くらい
宝石すくいあの ufoキャッチャーの外れの方の保全に買ってみました
いやーの本当に重罪に綺麗だなぁと思って買ってみたんですよ
あちょっと綺麗じゃんでめっちゃ綺麗でもイヤー万寿台綺麗ですね
パリッと呼びで男の前が何縫製集めてんだよ
きもって言われるかもしれないんですけどもいいんです
というわけであのちょっとこれ買ったにもちゃんと理由がありましてを経ネオ経営に色
沿いたいんですよもが少ないことだけが放さ品
美しいんじゃないなぁみたいなと思いましてねやっぱも長年では綺麗なんですけども
を政府とはまた違うんですよながあってからこその抑えと言われる掛け付き始めたので
僕はこのうまい棒をたくさん見てもあの一緒に押されたと思っておりますそれではなく
4枚目の宝石を使って何をしようかと言います十皇子で最も来たなそんな場所どこだと
思いますそトイレトイレこの4万円の宝石で照らすと
だろうって多分なんですけど世界で一番きれいで美しいくてかわいい
beautiful キュートといるにあると僕は思うんですよだってトイレ入るため
に宝石に囲まれるんですよそんな幸せな気持ちであの
なに破れ等したり出したりあ出すことしかないんですけどすごいハッピーな気持ちで
抑えのトイレになるんだと思いましてたよ宝石箱を置いていこうと思います調べた
ところ
1個約2キロぐらいなんで40キロ分の宝石をトイレでこちらね低知能トイレ乙要する
方の声を聞いてみたいと思いますではいこうと呼びでトイレですはい
何もねーといると言えば海好きなんだよなぁ
まだここにある調クリステルぐらい何でもないんですよね
あれだ俺おいたなぁただ問題はこの髪でトイレがとりくらいいっぱいになるかなんです
よ
そうで見るようにどれ誰から何が起きたにもエラーなんて後にラックすごいじゃんだよ
何かトイレの水で先発したんかな
tee
じゃあしちゃっていざ待って
では問題な問題が次いだぞ問題が発生したぞ
デザイン
を知っ
[音楽]
ん
ああああんん
基本床だけなんですけども入ってるギター宝石40kg に埋まってしまったと a
こんなにきれいだとさすがにみんなテンション上がるんじゃないでしょうか
でもねと思いわー
しまって出ちゃういたんだけど
痛いんですよだれほどのちくちくの部分が挑戦に触ってで結構笑えない痛みなんでえ
みなさん綺麗とは思いつつもされていることは多分
言いたい
痛い痛いって言うと思いますチームには時が有るまで本当にまだいない旅の舌と
みなせるが待つ今そうでは
tantan あった
持っています
水
事例
[音楽]
ええええええ
me
バッハ